my guy how are you oh
hey let's go let's get right in there
i'm carlos pleasure to meet you
so namor is a big big big deal to marvel
to marvel fans the original mutant one
of the og's oh here he goes
i mean you you get to fulfill this role
i know it's a responsibility but what
does it feel like to be able to
put namor in this particular story and
be this be the story to introduce him to
the whole world i think i think is the
the
right place to introduce neymar and
introduce all the world around him
because
it's not just
the right moment it's
the right director
the right producer
the right cast
and even the crew
you know so
it was so
i was so lucky to be part of this you
know and
and the way they take the story they
create this new world for this old
character
it's amazing you know it's a this
representation and the
way they made it
it's uh
it's fantastic and i hope
the people
can appreciate that and feel
part of this
because all of us we are part of this
that's why this movie
is particularly
touchy and deep
you know
because everybody can feel
part of this world
man congratulations thank you for the
time appreciate you thank you very much